deux arrêtés municipaux rappel la loi
l'un date de 1998
celui ci a été rédigée en 2016 ils
interdisent la pratique du nudisme sur
l'ensemble du littoral de la commune de
sainte anne
une commune qui compte 22 km de plage
s'est arrêté rappelle l'article 222-3 de
de loi du code pénal l'exhibition
sexuelle imposée à la vue d'autrui dans
un lieu accessible aux regards du public
est puni d'un an d'emprisonnement et de
15000 euros damende un texte qui fait
référence également aux nombreuses
plaintes formulées par les usagers des
plages sur le comportement agressif des
nudistes
c'est intéressant
des panneaux qui sont régulièrement
arraché par healy à la loi et son
application très limité et difficile à
respecter on fait d'abord la pédagogie
c'est à dire qu'on explique à ces
personnes que c'est un lieu public que
tout le monde doit pouvoir fréquenter en
toute liberté
et alors en général ça se passe bien les
personnes partent évidemment complice
s'éloigne elles reviennent bon c'est
véritablement à un vrai souci pour la
municipalité qui a effectivement le
pouvoir de police sur les plages son
territoire mais je crois personnel la
mairie ne dispose que de deux policiers
municipaux pour faire respecter la
réglementation sur les plages
un personnel et des parfois par les
gendarmes sur des opérations très
ponctuel